[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today this
question comes from Thomas in Colorado
he says I'm struggling to know how much
we actually need to retire I'm 54 and
currently have 1.4 million in a 401k
which sounds like a lot to me but I
don't actually know how fast we'll burn
through that what's the best way to know
how much I'll actually need so I'm
thinking about your the goal you don't
want to burn through your nest egg right
you want to have it invested in such a
way that you're able to live off of the
interest and not really touch the nest
egg is what I would say
um so that would be my first thought is
I would use a calculator and kind of run
this back and go okay what is what's the
income that I think I'm going to need
and get that number and then okay what
does the draw off of my interest need to
be what does my nest egg need to be so
that my draw can equal that so I'm kind
of reverse engineering it in that way
and then there's also the part of this
you know you're 54. I'm thinking okay
you've got 1.4 million now there's a
good chance that in seven years it could
double and that ain't bad yeah if you've
got an invested at 10 or better it
doubles every seven years yeah ten
percent or better yeah so it's 61 if
you're invested in good mutual funds
you're going to have uh 2.8 and at 68
you know you're gonna have five and a
half million dollars now there is
inflation to play into that no I'm just
talking about I'm not talking about
afflictions but I'm just saying that if
you're if you're making 10 it doubles
every seven years a lump sum does that's
if you're adding nothing to it okay so
at 68 that's what you would have if you
don't touch this now if you got to
retirement and all you had was 1.4
million then the way you how would you
calculate if that's enough just like
Jade said there's a couple of factors
there's inflation uh that you want to
stay away from and you need to look at
your rate of return so if you're
invested in good growth stock mutual
funds that are averaging what the stock
market is averaged the stock market is
average 11.8 percent since it began the
standard and poor okay
so let's just pretend you're making 11
we'll round down for the people that go
bananas when I start talking about this
stuff
all right so we're gonna round down
you're making 11 all right if you left
three in there
that would so that it would grow a
little bit to cover some inflation and
pulled off eight uh that means you'd be
living on ninety thousand dollars a year
eight percent one point four right with
no debt yeah and so can you do that
that's the question and if you can do
that in today's dollars you can do that
in tomorrow's dollars because if you
leave this alone because it will have
grown that much more that's right all
right and so if you did that the account
is growing by three percent a year if it
averages an 11 rate of return also good
point so you're still getting more money
never burns up it runs in perpetuation
it's a perpetual motion machine and this
is another good time to bring in why we
think it's and teach that it's so
important to be debt free with a paid
for Helm at retirement because you don't
need any bills you don't need as much
money to live on yeah and then it keeps
you from doing this but let's say you
start stepping on it okay and you step
on the principal a hundred thousand
dollars a year
when are we going to start that at 70
that takes you to 84. so you're not
going to run out of money if you just if
you look at your burn rate on your
principal as well so you're going to be
fine you've done a great job now the
trick is what I would suggest is we keep
earning a living and leave this money
alone and let's let it double A couple
more times before we start uh then then
you can pull off you know 200 000 a year
that's right I mean you're sitting on
five million instead of 1 million it's a
whole different equation dude and so and
again good growth stock mutual funds we
suggest uh I split my personal 401K Jade
does two uh among four types growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international and over the last 30 years
my little portfolio of that has averaged
over 12 most gears over 13 percent wow
Dave that's great but I mean it's not
really hard to beat the s p the s p is
the average of the market so what do you
want to be I always kind of want to be
above average hello you know I mean
that's you know try to beat it a little
bit but you know you stay in that north
of 10 and you draw in that seven or
eight range you're gonna bump up and
cover inflation as you go along now uh
you know some of the wonky
uh
Certified Financial Pharisees types you
know they go bananas on that calculation
but here's the thing I try to get people
to remember is when we've done studies
of people that win with retirement none
of them won with retirement because of
some nuanced understanding of 12 B1 fees
or some discussion about Point 11.8
versus 12.3 or 10.2 that none of that
caused them to retire well will cause
them to retire well is they actually put
money in the freaking
401K there's a high correlation between
people that have money and people that
save money why is this hard that's so
good it's not a bunch of freaking Theory
you've got to do it and oh my God you
nerds drive me bananas
so yeah just it's good to be thoughtful
about things but at some time sometimes
you just gotta do something you know
just run up and knock the crap out of
something well what if you're a person
that's like Dave I just I just invest in
my you know know my index funds that's
fine I I don't want to get into all this
stuff I just want to do my indexes
that's fine you're just average
you're just average average return
you're a c student
well that's what average isn't it you're
not failing but nobody's looking at
yourself a lot of money on the table
Yeah you left some money out there
that's okay I just want to beat it just
because it's a game you know I don't
care and by the way none of that is
what's making me wealthy what's making
me wealthy is the fact I'm actually
investing
you actually put money in overtime over
the long hauls the habits the you know
we saw these millionaires we go okay did
you know was it the rate of return that
made you a millionaire no what major
millionaire every month I put money in
for 27 years and now I got 2.8 million
dollars
they're just a tortoise it's just like
one step ugly tortoise ugly tortoise
ugly tortoise we need to print up
tortoise t-shirts you can wear that one
Dave
[Laughter]
get on the air with my wife slamming my
fashion choices here you don't like my
tortoise t-shirt I'll let you wear it
and then we'll point to we'll just point
to it on you just point to the toys
the little pudgy tortoise that could now
you said that part not me